sonic the hedghog famously went through
a drastic design change for his first
Hollywood film fans were so upset at
this that the filmmakers went back to
the drawing board and came up with a
much more familiar design but this
wasn't the first time Sonic went through
some growing pains so how did we get
from this to this the story begins in
1990 artists know to Oshima in
programmer yuji naka were tasked with
creating a new mascot for sega a video
game company that was emerging as a
popular contender to Nintendo
they held a competition within the
company which got them a bunch of
characters to choose from including this
Teddy Roosevelt looking man in pyjamas
who was ultimately used as the basis for
Sonic's nemesis dr. Eggman of 200 plus
sketches submitted this bunny rabbit and
a bowtie was an early favorite naka
imagined the rabbit picking up items
with his ears and throwing them at
enemies you can easily see the rabbit
similarities to Sonic
blufor big round eyes gloves and pointy
shoes however when programming a demo
version of the game with the rabbit it
was clear to naka that players would be
pressing too many buttons to control him
so he and Oshima went back to square one
they wanted a character that could use
its own body as a weapon because the
Sega mascot needed to appeal to
Americans Oshima took some designs to
Central Park and asked random New
Yorkers what they thought
New Yorkers had a dog a hedgehog and a
Teddy Roosevelt character to choose from
and they overwhelmingly chose the
Hedgehog and his name was mr. needle
mouse needle Mouse is the literal
translation of the Japanese word for
Hedgehog but thankfully that soon
changed to Sonic as naka was keen on
making a game that featured supersonic
speed Sonic's design was meant to be so
simple that he could be drawn by kids
similar to Mickey Mouse Oshima said that
this simplicity allowed sonic to
transcend race and gender sonic has
rounded quills so he can ball up and
pick up speed he was given smooth blue
fur to match the color of Sega's logo
his shoes with the buckle were designed
to be like something Michael Jackson
would wear and the red and white color
scheme was inspired by the album cover
of Michael Jackson's bad and Santa
Clause he had one large eyeball with two
black pupils in a bean shaped nose he
wore white gloves and socks and his body
parts were round and cartoonish then it
came time to give sonic a personality
Oshima credited sonic school get it done
attitude to former President Bill
Clinton as Sonic's mission in the first
few games is to free woodland creatures
from capture sonic also had an American
girlfriend named Madonna but an animal
having a human love interest was deemed
too weird by Sega more on this later
this version of Sonic the Hedgehog
proved to last throughout most of the
90s while Sonic's first game came out in
1991 the characters first appearance was
in a racing game called rad mobile he
was the ornament on the rear view mirror
a miniature version of the classic 90s
style Sonic went on to star in a number
of sequels and spin-offs like Sonic
Spinball while Sonic's head to body
ratio was changed from sonic the
hedgehog 2 sonic the hedgehog 2 his
basic design stayed the same this
version of Sonic was also featured in
two popular TV shows at the time
Adventures of Sonic the Hedgehog and
Sonic the Hedgehog as well as a series
of comics from publisher Archie Comics
Sonic wouldn't see a truly major design
change until 1998 with the release of
Sonic Adventure on the Sega Dreamcast
Sonic Adventure marks the first game
that features a modern sonic you won't
get away with this you
an artist UGA Kawa was in charge of his
makeover and because of the Dreamcast's
new technical abilities he found himself
with many challenges to overcome for
instance for most Sonic games before
Sonic Adventure sonic is seen from the
side this time though the camera was
behind him it was clear to Wakaba that
Sonic's proportions had to change so you
could see his body more clearly his
quills became sharper and doubled in
size his nose arms and legs got longer
overall he became more angular and less
round and he lost his potbelly Sonic
smooth blue fur became a darker shade of
blue and his eyes became green to
contrast with his skin hue Kawa cites
Akira Toriyama's line calligraphy as his
influence Toriyama is famous for having
created two characters for Dragon Ball Z
and is the reason this new Sonic looked
as why Kawa has said more graffiti or
street like Sonic was no longer cute he
was cool to double down on this new
Western coolness Sonic Adventure 2 in
2001 gave sonic shoes that looked more
like American sneakers much like the old
version of Sonic this new version was
featured in peripheral TV shows and
comics Sonic games since then haven't
delineated too much on his design in
2006 however Yuji naka wanted to create
a Sonic game with the more realistic
tone the game simply called Sonic the
Hedgehog reintroduced the concept of
another human love interest for Sonic
Elyse is a princess who has a secret
power that dr. Eggman wants to exploit
Sonic saves her time and time again
because Sonic had to interact with the
lease of full-sized human they made him
slightly taller and more mature
[Music]
nice smile
that game let alone that relationship
was seen as a huge failure and prompted
Sega to return to a lighter tone for
Sonic games a 2008 game called Sonic
Unleashed introduced a werehog version
of Sonic in which she became furry and
muscular in the sonic boom franchise
launched in 2014 to make Sonic look more
like what audiences recognize in a hero
art director Bob ruff a gave him
bandages tattered hair and a scarf this
design gave us another radical deviation
from the traditional Sonic design and
that this version had blue arms instead
of flesh colored ones this franchise is
seen as an outlier in terms of Sonic's
appearance though as the modern Sonic is
still being used in other games and
media that leads us to Sonic the
Hedgehog the film produced by Paramount
Pictures
initially the designers for the film
created a sonic that was supposed to
resemble a realistic Hedgehog the eyes
were small he had creepy human-like
teeth and generally looks like a small
child in a onesie it was a disaster
Sonic fans hated the design so much that
director Jeff Fowler promised he would
change it to better reflect Sega's
modern version of Sonic paramount
released a new updated trailer in early
2020 the revamped sonic looks much
better but there are still a few
differences the biggest one is his eyes
paramount version of Sonic has two
eyeballs
whereas Sega's version famously only has
one with two pupils his arms are blue
like the sonic boom version and the new
design also fades Sonic's new fur into
his tan mouth for a slightly more
realistic depiction in the movie he has
noticeable firm versus the smooth skin
on Sega's version of Sonic paramount
also gave its Sonic's some cool new
sneakers similar to the one seen in
Sonic Adventure 2 overall Paramount's
version seems to be a combination of all
the Sonic's we've seen thus far while
sticking
to the 90s a stetic sonic has come a
long way from Teddy Roosevelt and
rabbits to the live-action form we see
today but the latest backlash just goes
to show that fans prefer the Sonic they
grew up with in the 90s and that change
isn't always a good thing
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you